[Musique]
c'est le mali comme je suis tellement
excitée que je sois aujourd'hui avec
vous donc
la barre elle est hot il y avait
d'autres est speaker inspirant avec moi
donc je vais parler aujourd'hui
d'identité donc combien de fois on est
on est évalué sur la base des apparences
combien de fois on évalue aussi sur sur
son sur la base des apparences comme
bien des fois aussi on est un écart
entre la façon comment les gens nous
regardent versus que nous comment on
s'évaluer donc la définition d'identité
il y en a plusieurs définitions il ya
psychologiques sociologiques nationale
et même professionnel si paradoxalement
c'est tout si c'est définition de
l'identité font référence
c'est ce qui nous différencie qu'est ce
qui nous rapproche aussi pour moi c'est
quoi l'identité d'identité c'est
l'ensemble de nos choix de nos valeurs
de notre croyance c'est ce qui nous
guide avec la relation avec les autres
avec soi et avec les autres aussi
l'identité 6 c où notre vie s'appuie sur
l'identité si les gris aussi de
relations avec nous mêmes c'est c'est ce
qui guide ou si les relations avec
l'être avec soin et influence notre
cheminement est notre réussite
je suis né à fès et j'ai grandi à fès
donc le carrefour de cultures et de
civilisations donc la persévérance
l'optimisme ils font partie de notre
identité c'est des caractères de
typiquement marocain que j'ai transféré
avec moi dans mon pays d'accueil donc
mais il fallait bien sûr une ouverture
d'esprit pour intégrer d'élise éléments
des notions puis du comportement de
2 du canada aussi donc
traditionnellement dans la culture
marocaine on est un peu fataliste
quand il ya des situations qui arrive
c'est toujours on l'être ubu à au sort
ou destin est toujours en tire des
circonstances c'est selon ce qu on va
privilégier ou ne pas privilégier dont
au canada c'est la réaction instinctive
face à l'échec ou à une situation c'est
faire une introspection sur nous-mêmes
et voir la personne idoine à il doit
voir comment il peut réagir différemment
et adopter les comportements pour
s'éloigner de l'échec donc donc c'est ça
pue ou si il faut savoir toujours il ya
une relation entre la situation et
l'attitude
donc on a une situation devant nous il
faut pas juste l'observer mais non il
faut trouver la façon comment
l'interpréter et l'accueillir ça c'est
important
donc je suis je suis parti au canada
j'avais 24 ans donc un statut de
visiteur
on me fait utilise d'art pas d'argent
comme tous les marocains pas
d'expérience pas de confiance en moi
c'est normal on venait j'avais 24 ans
donc
donc j'ai capital et donc quand je suis
arrivé au canada may mon premier emploi
s'étaient un emploi dans un commerce de
détail
ça veut dire je faisais de la vente
après un certain l'année cet emploi ne
m'a porté aucune satisfaction
personnelle
donc j
je me voyais pas travailler dans cet
emploi là pour plusieurs années et la
seule chose que j'ai gagné de cet emploi
là aussi pu luce a confiance en moi j'ai
appris à avoir confiance en moi
ne sachant pas quoi faire mes frères il
faut l'informatique donc j'ai décidé de
faire l'informatique comme eux donc je
me suis inscrite à l'université après un
non aucune satisfaction personnelle ou
si je me voyais pas faire ça j'étais
insatisfait de m'en sors donc c'était le
point tournant dont ma carrière si ce
moment-là de satisfaction la première
chose que j'ai faite c'est plus poser
des questions sur mon identité faire la
liste de noms force de nous faiblesse ce
qu'on aime ce qu'on n'aime pas nos
passions ça veut dire qu'on se réveille
le matin
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire dans leur
qu'est ce qu'on va faire pour atteindre
nos objectifs qu est ce qu on aime faire
être heureux dans la vie donc donc avec
ça donc j'ai fait toutes mes yeux ma
liste de mes forces et mes faiblesses et
aussi j j il fallait que je trouve un
domaine de référence personnelle pour
moi aussi comment je peux capitaliser
sur mail différence et réussir dont en
tant que que différentes dans un milieu
qui n'est pas le mien
donc qui est le canada donc j j'y
travaillais sur sur sur des
caractéristiques pour que je sois plus
uniques et attractif pour se bat pour ce
pays il a donc appris après quand j'ai
fait ma liste et qu'est ce que je
voulais faire dont la vie est ce que
j'aime je n'aime pas et ma passion bien
sûr donc je me suis inscrite à
l'université à hec et j'ai fait mon bac
en finance donc j je savais que c'est là
c'est là
c'est la voie que je veux travailler et
la voie que je veux suivre
professionnellement la première chose à
faire quand j j j'ai pris mon diplôme
il fallait que je cherche un emploi la
première chose j'ai capitalisé sur mes
traitements auxquels donc mais très
marocains sont la connexion facilité de
parler négociations et vendre ça c'est
tout les marocains ils ont cette
caractéristique
donc j'ai monté un réseau de contacts
qui vraiment solide qui me permet
actuellement d'atteindre mes objectifs
et même les dépasser et en même temps
et au même temps trop plu ici ma
carrière
et quand j'ai monté mon réseau de
contacts
j'ai commencé à chercher de l'emploi
effectivement j'ai trouvé je trouvais
j'ai fait j'ai passé des entrevues dans
des banques et il y avait un poste que
j'ai aimé que je voulais avoir ses
directeurs de comptes commercial
entreprise donc j'ai fait entrevue il a
la réponse attardé beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de venir donc ça a pris
beaucoup de 2 d'attendre deux semaines
que j'étais anxieuse
donc j'ai eu là la job j'ai eu l'emploi
et quand j'ai rejoint l'équipe j'ai
demandé à mon patron j'ai dit je
comprends pas pourquoi ça a pris
tellement de temps pour me répondre
alors il ya d'autres personnes que vous
avez répondu en une semaine deux il m'a
dit battue c'est fatigant c'est avec ce
qui se passe actuellement avec les
arabes en été en 2004 après 2004 2005
je dois rajouter pas sûr que tu sera
compatible avec mon équipe
imaginez cette personne là il m'a défini
selon mme à montmagny citer mon origine
ethnique ma langue ma religion
donc j'ai travaillé avec cette
passion-là plusieurs années j'étais la
personne la plus performante la plus
respectée la plus efficace de son équipe
donkey cette personne là il venu me voir
pour me dire et côtier avec toi que j'ai
appris qu'ils fait pas juger par la
longue pas juger par par l'origine
ethnique mais plutôt sur les compétences
les compétences de la personne et bien
sûr ma vision mais ma vision différente
des choses je suis une personne très
créatif dans la façon comment je pense
ça a aidé l'équipe à a créé des
solutions innovantes
effectivement pour propulser son équipe
et il m'a même demandé 2
de lui recommander un candidat marocain
puis ça a été finalisé pour pour une
embauche donc après 7,7 emploi et là ma
carrière a pris une tangente ascendante
incroyable couronné de plusieurs succès
jeu redéfinissait toujours les rôles qui
me sont attribués donc moi j'ai un rôle
je peux pas il faut le définir il faut
avoir une vision différente si on peut
si on peut progresser
donc je redis fini aucun objectif
il n'est qu'un croyable ou impossibles
on est capable d'atteindre toutes les
objectifs qui s'enfuit donc de façon
naturelle
j'ai commencé à gérer des équipes de
vente donc j'ai deux équipes de vente
j'ai toujours comme me l'a dit ndèye des
speakers tout à l'heure il faut avoir un
rêve puis il faut avoir les moyens pour
pour y arriver pour quelqu'un comme moi
qui arrive pas l'expérience en gestion
tout d'un coup définit ce que je voulais
faire et je voulais être un leader de
vente et je suis allé dans le de vente
donc
donc je voulais toujours être un leader
de vendre ses parts par soif de pouvoir
mais plutôt pour avoir l'autorité de
d'implémenter des choses que tu es pas
capable de le faire si ton nez tu un
employé normal aussi
j
je voulais toujours faire l impact sur
la vie des gens sur la vie de mes
clients sur la vie de mes collègues sur
les gens qui m'ont mon entourage un
impact positif développer les gens les
aider à aller à un autre niveau ce si
important chacun de nous il doit
travailler puis accompagner les gens qui
sont aux alentours de nous donc comme
quand j'ai commencé aussi à cette banque
là il ya vu un de mes mentors sylvie
marois je lui dis que je vais lui rendre
hommage ce soir qui m'a qui m'a vraiment
elle a su me développer et connaître me
mets mes forces et mes talons avant même
que moi je le je le sache donc
actuellement jugée une équipe de deux de
21 personnes
j'aimerais bien vous les montrez de 21
personnes
j'ai quinze nationalités imaginez la
diversité d'identité de ces personnes là
si c'est un actif
incroyable si on sait comment les
développer comment les encourager ça va
être un outil incroyable qui crée du
dynamisme et qui va amener juste au
succès tout le monde regarde la photo
donc j j j'ai connu plusieurs
je suis tellement fière de mon
cheminement et où je suis arrivé
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas l'intention d'y
arrêter au contraire j j'ai plein de
projets j'ai plein de choses je me pose
toujours les questions suivantes comment
je peux devenir la perle rare que tout
le monde veut avoir dans son camp
comment je peux est ce que ma vision
elle est encore d'actualité
est ce que mes valeurs j'aurai je suis
encore fidèle à mes valeurs
est ce que mes compétences sont encore
ancré dans mon identité
ça c'est des questions que je pose
toujours
pour trouver des façons d'être encore
meilleur donc si vous avez bien bien
suivi ce qu'on a ce que je vous dis
depuis tout à l'heure le point le point
charnière de deux mondes parcours it et
cette introspection que j'ai fait au
début de ma carrière c'est ça ce qui m'a
permis de savoir ce que je voulais faire
et je me suis créé les outils de les
faire et les outils offerts aussi
définir mes identités les faire
canaliser et trouver des atouts vraiment
spécifique et unique qui me différencie
des autres
c'est ça ce qui fait comme quoi je suis
arrivé où je suis arrivé aujourd'hui
est ce que je vaux je vous demande c'est
c'est toujours posez vous la question si
des questions simples qu'est ce que vous
aimez
qu'est ce que vous aimez le moins qu'est
ce que vous voulez faire c'est quoi
c'est quoi la définition du succès 7 ces
questions là ils sont tellement simples
à répondre mais si vous commencez à la
réponse ça vous donne un mal de tête
incroyable
prenez le temps de se redéfinir savoir
qu'est ce que vous aimez qu'est ce que
vous aimez pas qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire ça si important pour pour les gens
l'aiment 1h05 assumant ce que je vous
dis aussi assume en assumant nounou
farce assumant nounou passion
assumant nos rêves
assumant aussi nous échec et nous et
nous et nous faiblesse soyons fidèles à
nous mêmes que respectant nos valeurs et
soyons nous-mêmes ça c'est très
important
le travail sur soi c'est un travail de
toute une vie vous allez voir ma photo c
c'est toute une vie ça veut dire si
c'est un travail qui durent des années
et des années c mais c'est réellement
passionnant quand vous arrivez à la
version finale de vous je vous mets
juste cette photo pour savoir de 1980
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est un travail de
toute une vie qui il me reste encore des
années donc prenez le temps de se poser
ces questions simples et définissez vous
c'est votre clé du succès merci